And finally, New Rule.
If humanity can impose rules
on warfare,
let's do something
really ambitious.
Let's try them on high school.
(SMACKS LIPS)
Because our public schools
are no longer safe
for the teachers.
A 15-year-old in Houston
this year sucker-punched
his teacher
for confiscating his phone
after screaming,
"Give me my phone,
I told you to give me
my fucking phone."
-KID: I told you
to give me my phone.
-Hey, Sprint,
you may have
a new spokesperson.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
In Florida,
a high school student beat
a teacher's aide unconscious
for taking his Nintendo Switch.
-(AUDIENCE GROANING)
-Hitting the teacher?
I used to get sent
to the principal's office
for rolling my eyes.
-(AUDIENCE CHUCKLING)
-Go online.
You can see endless videos
of this stuff.
Of kids threatening
and punching teachers.
-What is this, JetBlue?
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
What have we let
our schools turn into?
A third of teachers
in America say
they've been harassed
or threatened.
And one in seven in this country
has been physically attacked.
2023 kicked off with the story
of a six-year-old boy taking
a gun to school
in Newport News, Virginia,
shooting his teacher,
and then declaring,
-"I shot that bitch dead."
-(AUDIENCE MURMURING)
Which would be a cool last line
for a Mickey Spillane novel.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-But a six-year-old?
The librarian at the school
added some context to the story,
saying... (READS PROMPT)
No wonder 50 percent
of teachers expressed a desire
to quit or transfer
to something less dangerous,
like walking Joe Biden's dog.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
No wonder 86 percent
of public schools
have a teacher shortage.
Because 20 years ago,
if you said
"American high school,"
people pictured this.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-Now, they picture this.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
(CHUCKLES)
Only eight percent of schools
say it's easy
to even find bus drivers.
Few weeks ago,
some Oklahoma middle schoolers
were acting up on the bus.
So, the driver pulled over
and said
he wasn't gonna go anywhere
until they quieted down.
So, the kids immediately obeyed
because he was the adult.
-I'm joking, of course.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
They went even more batshit.
-Sit down!
-(KIDS SHOUTING INDISTINCTLY)
-No! Sit down!
And when school officials
reviewed video of the incident,
all those kids were punished.
-(SCOFFS) I'm joking again.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
Of course the kids
were given counseling
and the driver
was fired, arrested,
and charged with child abuse.
And that
is the root of our problem.
Moms and dads used
to have the backs of teachers
and authority figures.
But now, their precious progeny
can never do anything wrong.
So, it's made education
impossible.
And I know you're saying,
"Bill, what do you know
about it? You never had kids."
(CLICKS TONGUE) I know, jealous.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
-(LAUGHS)
But I know this.
A teacher today
looks out every morning
and sees 25 phones
distracting 25 kids.
Undeterred by any authority
to pay attention
or even be civil.
And each kid represented
by the high-powered
legal defense team
-of mom and dad.
-(AUDIENCE CHUCKLING)
No, I'm sure
there are parents seeing this
and saying, "That's not us,
and this isn't our experience."
True. Not all schools
are violent and scary.
But they are all diploma mills
that allow students to graduate
without demanding
the kids know basic shit.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
-So--
Twenty-five years ago,
George W. Bush asked,
"Is our children learning?"
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-True.
Well, it's only gotten worse.
Only 33 percent
of U.S. children can read
at a level of proficiency.
If you're attending
an American high school now,
that's about one-third.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
So, I'm not surprised
that home schooling
is America's fastest growing
form of education.
And not just
with weirdo Christian families
who make their daughters wear
a bonnet.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-To millions of parents,
anything is better now
than public education,
and that includes
Catholic school.
You know in 1970,
only 2.7 percent of the kids
who went to Catholic school
were not Catholic.
Now, it's 22 percent. Yeah.
Catholic school eighth graders
are two full grade levels
above public school kids.
Because their school
isn't a safe space
for fucking off.
They're told no you can't be
on your phone here.
And your pronouns
are shut up and sit down.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
How fucked up
is this country... (CHUCKLES)
...that to get
a no bullshit education now,
you have to go to the place
that's completely
based on bullshit.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
BILL MAHER:
What we need... (LAUGHS)
What we need in this country
is a chain of non-Catholic
Catholic schools.
-And...
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
...since many celebrities
have opened their own schools--
Oh, yeah.
That's how serious we are
about education in America.
-We let celebrities do it.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
LeBron has one.
George Clooney, Pitbull.
Tony Bennett had one.
Andre Agassi. Kanye had one.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
Well, now,
I'm thinking of doing it
and opening
Bill Maher's Catholic School.
(AUDIENCE CHEERING, APPLAUDING)
It's like
traditional Catholic school,
just without the religion
and the molesting.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
At Bill Maher's Catholic School,
-we do school, old-school.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
With a curriculum
called "School Classic."
Rule one, no phones all day.
No exceptions.
(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING, CHEERING)
Not just so
the kids aren't distracted
when they're trying to learn,
but also because it forces
hovering parents to leave them
the fuck alone for eight hours.
-(AUDIENCE CHEERING, APPLAUDING)
-You're their parent,
not their probation officer.
Other rules include
no making up a disorder
that allows your kid
to get more time on the test.
We call that by
its original name, "cheating."
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
-No participation ribbons.
No turning in anything late.
No vaping.
No emotional support animals.
And of course,
if the student doesn't maintain
a C average or higher,
absolutely no sex
with the teacher.